Library of Congress
Kluge Prize Ceremony
>> Dignified, bold,
compassionate.  Dedicated.
Rounded, open, engaged.
>> Elegant.
Visionary, strong, thoughtful
and diplomatic.
The Kluge Prize awards
accessible scholarship and
strong public leadership.
And Drew Gilpin Faust embodies
all the
traits we were seeking as a
prize recipient.
DREW GILPIN FAUST: I see myself
fundamentally as a historian.
I grew up in Shenandoah Valley
crk Virginia, when time was
changing, but
when history was very present in
the
1950s and 60s we lived in the
midst of civil war battlefields,
but the emerging time of Civil
Rights Movement, brown v.
Board, the effort to close
schools in
jirnlings through mass -- in
Virginia through mass
resistance, all of that when I
was a small child.  The
questions for past and present
intersected for me vividly as
the
American traditions of
governance and race and justice
and equality all played out
before my eyes, but also were
part
of what I was hearing about the
places in which I lived and
their history.
SPEAKER: I think a great choice
for the Kluge Prize for
Achievement in the Study of
Humanity.  She's a humanist and
historian.  Life has been a
study of who we are and how we
deal with crises, but then
her life also has been an
exemplary leader through the
turbulent times that we all live
in.  So she not only has
researched and
studied this as a scholar for
all of us, she also exemplified
leadership and
humanity, and I think it's a
wonderful choice.
SPEAKER: Drew Faust is a
historian.  It's not just
science and technology, as
important as they are, it's the
values that are infused into
those technologies.
And that's where her background
helped to ensure that we were
constantly lifting our gaze to
the constellation of
possibilities.
SPEAKER: She has been a
historian of the
American south, of American
women, and of the American civil
war and the
intellectual history of the
South in particular, as
distinguished and as
important as anyone in the past
40 years.
Her work will always stand as
some of the most important
contributions to civil war
history, the history of the
South and the history of
American women.
SPEAKER: You have made a real
difference throughout your
entire professional career, and
I know that you will
continue to do so as you put it,
to help us build a more
enlightened world.
So congratulations and best
wishes on your future endeavors.
Drew, I want to congratulate you
on your service as a historian
and as an integrator in higher
education.
Thanks to you, both the general
public and our leaders have a
greater understanding of our
shared history, and the
experiences that have shaped our
nation.
SPEAKER: Dr. Hayden, members of
Congress, members of the
diplomatic corps and members of
the library's James Madison
council, scholars and
distinguished guests, I am
John has kill, director of the
Kluge center on behalf of the
Library of Congress, it is my
pleasure to welcome you to the
7th conferral of the John W.
Kluge Prize for the study of
humanity.
Incidentally, this event is
being recorded for placement on
the library's website and it is
being livestreamed, so I also
welcome our viewers from around
the world.
The John W. Kluge Prize for
achievement in the study of
humanity is unique among
international awards.
The prize covers fields,
virtually all the humanities and
social sciences and other areas.
It honors scholars who over a
sustained period have distilled
wisdom from the cumulative
record of human experience and
have had a major impact on
public life.
The selection progress is
Democratic and broad.  The
library solicits nominations
from a wide range of national
and international individuals
and institutions and uses a
rigorous selection process
involving curators, specialists
and a distinguished panel of
outside scholars and, of course,
the Librarian of Congress.
We are deeply grateful to the
late John W. Kluge for his
generosity in creating the
endowment that funds this prize,
as well as the wide-ranging
research of the many visiting
scholars that the Kluge center
here within the Thomas Jefferson
Building.
Now, here in this institutional
symbol
of the importance of knowledge
to our democracy, we especially
want to thank the Congress of
the United States for creating
and sustaining the library for
over two centuries, beginning
with Thomas Jefferson's amazing
collection, which has grown to
over 160 million items.  The
U.S. Congress has been the
greatest single patron of the
library in the history of the
world.  We thank the
distinguished members who are in
the audience and with us
tonight.
And now I have the honor to
introduce to
you the 14th Librarian of
Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden.
[Applause]
CARLA HAYDEN: Thank you.
I am so honored and pleased to
welcome all of the distinguished
guests tonight and thank you so
much for being here with us on
this very special evening.  John
has already told you a little
about the history of the Kluge
Prize,
but before we go any further,
I'd like to recognize one very
special person in our audience.
My pred sees ser, the 13th
Librarian of Congress, Dr. James
buildington.
[Applause]
CARLA HAYDEN: Dr. Billington had
the vision to create this prize,
as well as the Kluge center,
and he worked alongside the late
John W. Kluge to turn this dream
into reality.  We thank you for
your vision and for your many
years of service and leadership
to our nation.
It is now my great pleasure and
privilege to confer the 7th
Kluge Prize
for achievement in the study of
humanity.
Drew Gilpin Faust stands among
the most distinguished
historians of our generation.
Throughout her career she has
demonstrated clear vision and
intellectual courage, spending
countless
hours in the archives and among
primary resources, some right
here at the
Library of Congress, uncovering
the vital research and threads
of our country's social history.
Her work has added to our
understanding of the civil war,
the history of the South, and
the history of women in the
United States.
My granting us a greater
understanding
of our heritage and some of the
decisive
ideas and conflicts that shaped
it, her work continues to
provide context to the many
challenges we face in public
life today.
In addition to her skilled craft
as a historian and educator, she
has been a leader in the public
sphere.
In 2007, following her very
successful
tenure as dean of the Radcliffe
institute, she took office as
Harvard's 28th president.
And for over a decade at the
helm of one of the world's most
distinguished centers of higher
research and learning, she
guided the institution through a
time of national financial
crisis and during her leadership
she expanded financial aid for
undergraduates, working to make
the Harvard community more
diverse and accessible, and she
ably promoted the university's
mission in the arts, sciences
and humanities.
She also led in the creation of
innovative learning and
interdisciplinary programs and
strengthened the university's
international impact.
Dr. Drew Gilpin Faust, will you
please come forward to receive
the Kluge Prize for achievement
in the study of humanity?
Please join me in welcoming Dr.
Faust.
[Applause]
CARLA HAYDEN: And now we will
hear from our laureate.
DREW GILPIN FAUST: Thank you to
all of you for being here.  I
know how many things there are
to do in this city and that you
would choose to be here tonight
means the world to me.
And I wanted to especially thank
Carla Hayden for awarding me
this prize and for taking on the
Library of Congress.  It's just
about to be her second
anniversary as librarian,
September 14th.  So I think we
should have a round of applause
and congratulations to her.
[Applause]
DREW GILPIN FAUST: Dr.
Billingt on, secretary Chow, so
many distinguished friends in
this room.
I am so grateful for this award.
It's hard for me to find the
words to
convey that, and also to convey
how
humble I feel to be in the
pantheon of its recipients.
I'm delighted to be awarded this
recognition by the Library of
Congress, an institution that
has meant so much to me
throughout my scholarly career.
From the papers of 19th century
South Carolina congressman and
senator James Henry Hammond, a
key figure in my first two
books, to the diaries and
letters of
Clara Barton and the searing
Matthew Brady photographs so
central to my last.
The library's collections have
been essential to my
explorations of the
history of the American South
and the nation's experience of
civil war.
That this award comes from the
Library
of Congress is a signal honor.
That it is awarded for
Achievement in
the Study of Humanity is a
recognition I could scarcely
have dreamed of.
It affirms what I have seen as a
vocation, a calling, a life
purpose.
Both in my own dedication to
such
study, but also in my efforts on
behalf
of the institution's, especially
universities, that have enabled
and encouraged this pursuit.
The path I have chosen into the
study of humanity has been
history.
From my earliest years, which I
guess
I discussed already a little bit
on the video, growing up in
Virginia,
Shenandoah Valley in the 1950s
and '60s, I felt the presence of
the past all around me.
I lived on a farm on the Leeiac
son
High -- Lee Jackson highway
where confederates and Yankees
had skirmished and played civil
war with my brothers in the
woods near our house.
But I also knew, even as a young
child,
that my owner ra was a historic
time in its own right.
One of controversy and challenge
to
the entrenched order of
segregation that had replaced
slavery after the civil war.
History seemed to surround me,
even as a new history was being
created before my eyes.
The path of slavery, war and
racial injustice so present in
my childhood
would later become the focus of
my scholarly work.
But the questions I would ask of
the
19th century had implications
for my own world as well.
I sought through research and
writing to
understand how human beings had
come to
create the slave society of the
Old
South, and how slavery's
oppressions had
become, for millions of white
southerners, not just an
accepted way of
life but what they justified as
a positive good and what
ultimately, in
the hundreds of thousands, they
died to defend.
A century later I had grown up
amongst
adults who supported
segregation, a system that had
seemed to me, even as a young
child, at odds with the
Democratic
and Christian values those same
adults taught me to esspouse.
If I could understand the
southern
past, perhaps I could better
understand the southern present.
My Ph.D.
dissertation and my first book
were about the pro-slavery
argument.
You might say I wanted to
understand inhumanty.
How men and women throughout
history
have persuaded themselves to
defend
ideas, practices, societies,
governments, that we of a
different era see as
indefensible.
I wanted to know how humans can
become blind to evil.
Perhaps if we could understand
their
processes of denial and
rationalization,
we might gain insight into our
own failures of vision.
Those shortcomings of our own
time.
History, in other words, can
expand our awareness of
ourselves.
It releases us from the confines
of our own individual lives.
It offers us other ways of
seeing that cast our assumptions
into relief.
It reminds us of choices people
have
made or not made, and thus it
eliminates realms of
possibility.
It shows us that things have
been otherwise, and it reminds
us that things can be different
once again.
By documenting contingency and
agency,
history undermines any
acceptance of
crippling inevitablety, and
contingency means opportunity.
It means we can change things,
and that what we do matters.
To my mind, this is history's
most important lesson.
Although I at first focused my
attention on the society and
culture of
the Old South, the implications
of the questions I was exploring
in my writing
and teaching led me inexorabley
toward the civil war.  It seemed
I had been steeped in that war
since my earliest days.
As I began my deeper scholarly
explorations into its history, I
soon
came to understand Ernest
Hemingway's observations to F.
Scott Fitzgerald.
"War," he said, "is the best
subject.
"  For me it proved irresistible
to study humanity when under
maximum
pressure, when decisions and
choices are literally matters of
life and death.
When the possibility for the
best of
humanity, courage, sacrifice,
and the
worst of humanity, cruelly,
cruelty, brutality, when they
collide.
And I found myself drawn to
explore with my students other
wars as well.
Vietnam, the two world wars,
what was different?  And what
unchanging about the human
response to combat about
conflagration?
What was the product of time and
circumstance?
And what was the result of an
essential enduring humanity?
How did the inhumanty of war
compel its
participants to reaffirm and
reassert
what humanity truly meant?  And
how did war extend beyond the
battlefield to engulf the lives
of civilians, of women and of
children?
What, as we might put it, was
the human face of war?
It was in war's foregrounding of
death
that I encountered an
unparalleled line
of sight into the human
condition, and the subject for
my most recent book.
Mortality is a defining feature
of
humanity, and our recognition
and
anticipation of our inevitable
end is a key element
differentiating us from animals.
All of life and all of
philosophy once observed is
about learning to die.
Yet we do so in different ways,
in different eras and different
places.
Facing the unprecedented
slaughter of civil war, more
than 2% of the population died
in the course of the war, the
equivalent of about 7 million
people today.
Americans confronted death in a
manner both old and new.
The widely shared Christian
ideology of the good death
provided lessons in how
to die that shaped the response
to
unimaginable and unfathomable
industrialized slaughter.
The insistence of our forebears
on adapting the rituals and
practices that preserve their
humanity, even in the
face of catastrophe, seemed to
me an affirmation of the power
and resilience of the human
spirit.
Even in almost impossible
circumstances,
soldiers and civilians alike
struggle to bury, name and honor
the dead in ways that affirm the
value of each human life.
The National Cemetery System
that emerged from the war
represents the expression of
this impulse on a national
level.
For me, the research and writing
for
this book served as an excursion
into the past with powerful
resonance for a future that
awaits us all.
I have been deeply moved and
gratified
to learn that readers ranging
from
hospice workers to clergy to
active and veteran military have
found this book has spoken to
them and to their experience.
That is just a brief glimpse
into what
the study of humanity and
inhumanty has
meant for me, and the kinds of
questions that collections like
the ones here at the Library of
Congress have enabled me to ask.
Other institutions have, of
course, also
supported this work.  Which
would never have been
accomplished without the rich
intellectual environment of
teaching and research nurtured
by American higher education.
Universities have served as the
locus for humanistic inquiry
from the time of their founding
in the 11th century.
Society has assigned primarily
responsibility for this
stewardship to them.
It has been the unique role of
the university, both to serve
the immediate and urgent
present, and at the same time
to look beyond it, to pose
larger questions of meaning.
Not just to propel us towards
our
goals but to ask what those
goals should
be, to understand who we are,
where we came from and where we
are going and why.
Yet we find ourselves in a time
when the value and legitimacy of
these questions, and of the
fields that embody them, are
being criticized, weakened,
marginalized.
Increasingly education is seen
as instrumental.
We expect it to provide a direct
path to a specific job.
We fail to ask how it will
produce a
thoughtful citizen or a person
who can imagine beyond the
moment in which we
find ourselves to see and build
the changing world ahead.
Or how a leader can begin to
address
the profound impact of our
extraordinary technological
advances on our culture, our
society, and our very
understanding of what it is to
be human.
We see the results of this
neglect all around us.
We have invented the marvels of
social
media, but not figured out the
ethics of the profound
challenges it poses.
We have made torrents of
information
available to almost everyone,
but not equipped them with the
skills of analysis and habits of
discernment to separate truth
from falsehood, or
perhaps most alarmingly, to
believe that this distinction
matters.
We are a society enthralled by
the notion of innovation.
But how can we imagine a new
future
without grasping how things were
once different and can be
different again?
We are witnessing sharp declines
in the fields designed to ask
such questions and nurture such
skills.
I speak, of course, of the
humanities, and what are known
as the qualitative,
not mathematical, social
sciences.
Languages, literatures, history,
philosophy, religion,
anthropology, parts of
sociology, and political science
are at the core of this
endeavor.
And their departments, majors,
jobs and enrollments are
plummeting.
At Penn State, for example, the
five
years from 2010 to 2015 saw a
40% decline in humanities
majors.
At the University of Illinois at
Champaign urbana, there were 414
majors in 2005 and 155 in 2015.
Nationwide numbers of history
majors are
down 45% since 2007.  Since
1990s English majors have
declined by half.
The University of Wisconsin at
Stevens Point announced it would
abolish 13 departments, French,
German, Spanish, philosophy and
political science.
One state governor listed the
specific
fields to be favored with state
support
explicitly tying educational
resources to job outcomes.
He said, "I want to spend our
dollars
giving people sciences,
technology, engineering, math
degrees, so that when
they get out of school, they can
get a job."  He observed his
state did not need any more
anthropologists.
In fact, humanists do get jobs,
and over a lifetime earn only
slightly less than their peers
in the social and natural
sciences.
Jobs are, of course, important.
But they are not enough to serve
as the exclusive purpose of
higher education.
When we define the role of
learning solely to drive
economic development, we
risk losing sight of the broader
and
deeper questions of the kinds of
inquiry
that enable the critical insight
that
build the humane perspective
that foster the restless
skepticism and unbounded
curiosity from which our
profoundest understandings so
emerge.
We shouldn't for get Einstein's
words... "Not everything that
counts can be
counted and not everything that
can be counted counts."
It seems to me telling that one
set of higher education
institutions has not shared in
this recent decline in the
importance of the humanities.
These are our military
academies.
Take the example of West Point,
from
its origins as an engineering
school, the United States
Military Academy has
evolved over two centuries to be
a very special sort of liberal
arts college.
One that recognizes that many of
the
most significant lessons it can
impart
for leadership must emerge from
the study of humanity.
The academy describes it this
way:
"the expansion of a person's
capacity to know one's self and
view the world through multiple
lenses."
The distinguished academy
graduate general George Patton,
whose papers are here at the
Library of Congress insisted
that a successful soldier must
know history.
To win battles, he observed, you
do not beat weapons.  You beat
the soul of man.
Alexander the great slept with
two things under his pillow.
A dagger and a copy of Homer's
Illiad.  To understand the human
soul.  No small aspiration.
But one that has propelled my
work for decades and the work of
the humanities for millennia.
In identifying what is
distinctively human, we
necessarily commit ourselves
to its preservation and
enhancement, to the appreciation
of what unites us rather than
the distraction of what divides
us.
To the advancement of the humane
in a world that often seems bent
on destroying it.
We must support universities in
their dedication to these
efforts.
And we must adopt a discourse
that honors rather than
disparaging these fields of
inquiry.
But to make this possible and
sustainable within universities,
we must also build broader
understanding of the
importance of the study of
humanity outside and beyond
them.
And so let me return to where I
began, to where we find
ourselves tonight.
In serving as the Library of
Congress,
this institution must also serve
all the people that Congress
represents.
Not just scholars but the
curious citizens of an entire
nation.
All of us are in this room
because we
are in some way connected to
that work,
because we are somehow invested
in that endeavor.
The extraordinary advances of
science
and technology that lie before
us must
be shaped by human and humane
purposes
if those values and perhaps even
humankind are not to be
destroyed.
Let me invoke the historian's
sense of contingency that I
earlier described.
It is up to us to define the
nature and quality of human
possibility.
The contents of this library can
help
inspire us to inspire others to
understand what those
possibilities might be.
Let me make this point by
closing with a treasure from the
library.
I spoke earlier of the face of
war.
The Library of Congress
possesses a remarkable
collection of I understand
now more than 3500 civil war
pieces that
has been assembled and donated
by Tom lind qis, who is here in
the audience, and his three
young sons.
Inspired by newspaper
photographs of U.S.
servicemen and women killed in
Iraq and
Afghanistan, the Lindquist
regard their collection as a
memorial to the soldiers of the
civil war.
This gives you a general
portrait, but
here is one of the amber types
from the collection.
It's been tentatively identified
as Sergeant Samuel Smith.
His wife Molly and daughters,
Mary and Maggie.
The image was found in Cecil
County, Maryland, so it's likely
this soldier
was in one of seven regiments of
United
States Colored Troops raised  in
that state.
Like all of the portraits in
this collection, it speaks
eloquently to us across the
century and a half that
separates us.
For this soldier and his family,
the
message is one of pride, an
affirmation
of the new freedom's warhead
enabled him to claim.
Slavery would have denied him
the right
to legally marry or to protect
his wife and children from sale.
This portrait is of a free man.
It proclaims a new day for black
families, a new respectability
of fine clothing, and of
daughters in matching coats and
bonnets.
And it portrays a soldier, an
African American who under
slavery would have been
prohibited
from bearing arms, and who,
until 1863 could not have
enlisted in the Army.
Now he is joined what would be
nearly
200,000 other black Americans to
fight
for freedom, to risk enslavement
if captured, and to establish a
claim to
full citizenship and humanity as
the republic's old defenders.
In this photograph, Sergeant
Smith, or
whoever this might be, makes a
statement about a new order of
things.
It is his own Declaration of
Independence, his personal
affirmation
that all men, that he has been
created
equal, that he is fighting for a
new birth of freedom.
But these 3500 portraits and
thousands
more like them are intended to
send us another message as well.
One that speaks directly to the
meaning of the study of humanity
across time and space.
These soldiers staring into the
photographer's lens are
self-consciously reaching
through history.
They have documented their faces
and uniforms partly because they
know they may be killed in the
battles ahead.
But they also know they are
making history in this war.
And they want to capture that
for us.
Attention must be paid, they are
saying.
Don't forget who we were and
what we did.
Let us give you the means to see
us, to understand us, long after
we are gone.
Our present is delivered to us
at a price paid by those who
came before.
History helps us remember our
accountability to them, as well
as our obligations to more than
just ourselves
and more than just our own time.
It is a way of knowing and
valuing that has never mattered
more.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: Thank you for those
aspiring words, Dr. Faust, and
all of us at the library look
forward to working with you in
the future.  I know I can speak
for all of us on that.
And I now invite everybody to
make your
way upstairs for dinner, and
thank you again.
[Applause]